Williams Campo received a BA from
Trinity College University of Dublin in
Ireland 1952 and a PhD from University
of Wisconsin Madison Wisconsin in the
United States in 1957 it was with the
Merck Institute for therapeutic research
from 1957 and in 1984 he became the
senior scientist and director for sa
research and development Kapil is
currently a research fellow emeritus
Drew University Madison New Year's Eve
USA please join me in welcoming dr.
Campbell who will present his Nobel
lecture under the title either macton a
reflection on simplicity
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
you see from my title I intend to talk
about simplicity simplicity in the
context of science and in talking about
simplicity I do not mean to suggest that
science itself is simple
nor will I suggest that the discovery
and development of the drug
ivermectin was an exercise in simplicity
I want rather to call attention to the
element of simplicity within science and
I want to do that by pointing out the
prominence of simplicity in the genesis
of ivermectin it has of course long been
acknowledged and recognized that
simplicity has an intrinsic appeal to
scientists as it does to others and
indeed simplicity is widely celebrated
in science as a matter of beauty but I
want to talk about simplicity not as a
matter of beauty but as a matter of
practical utility consider a real-life
actual event on a particular day the 9th
of May 1975 there was a mouse in a mouse
box in a laboratory it had been
purposely infected with worms but not
enough to cause illness and on that
particular day the mouse's diet was
altered it was altered by having some
liquid stirred into its regular food and
it ate that food for almost a week and
then this regular diet was restored and
almost a week after that its worms were
gone the mouse had been cured of its
warming
and from that moment there was a train
of events set in motion that would lead
to an advance in medicine both human
medicine and veterinary medicine and
that advanced in the basic science would
in turn lead to practical changes in the
management of diseases so to a very
large extent the drug ivermectin was
brought about by simple science it is
not conventional science it was not
obvious science but it was simple
science I I want to make a slight
digression here in relation to another
question I have often been asked in
recent weeks how it felt when I heard
that I had won the prize and I can say
without hesitation that my mind was
instantly flooded with two emotions one
of the motion of joy and gratitude and
the other emotion one of sadness and the
sadness because I knew instantly that
all the people who contributed to this
drug and made it a success
could not be named individually and so I
am a representative of the American
company research team and in that
capacity I am grateful and honored
beyond imagining so what was in that
liquid that was added to the regular
food of that Mouse on the 9th of May it
was a liquid in which a microbe a
bacterium had been allowed to multiply
breaking down the surrounding nutrients
and producing all kinds of byproducts
metabolites of various kinds in other
words the liquids added to the diet had
been fermented by a bacterium and that
bacterium had been isolated and sent
murk and company and by dr. Satoshi
amaura whom you have just heard and who
shares with me the prize that has
brought us here together today and many
years later I had the pleasure of
visiting him in Tokyo microbes do not
all look alike or actual like but the
carousel of Institute and Merck both of
them were interested in finding microbes
that stand out from the crowd
microbiologist get tired of finding
microorganisms that have already been
found professor emeritus microbes that
were unfamiliar in general to
microbiologists and we found that one of
those unfamiliar microbes produced an
unfamiliar substance and that that
substance had very potent activity
against worm parasites and also against
some other parasites but that is a story
for another time is the mouse that I
mentioned was a single mouse I do not
mean that the mouse was unmarried
I mean I mean only that that that
special diet had been tested in only one
month usually things are tested in
groups of mice experimental groups but
that was tested in just one single Mouse
other individual mice got other diets
altered by other liquids in which other
bacteria had flourished but only one
Mouse only one of those liquids ended in
the cure of worms excuse me for moments
but that test method which might strike
you as unusual was developed in the
parasitology department of american
company by dr. john egerton and that is
also in the same department dr. dan
Ostend had pioneered the reduction of
experimental group size to a singleton
simplicity in the history of ivermectin
was just a beginning from then on there
was complexity many years of basic
complex research and many years of
complex developmental research
pharmaceutical development is the
epitome not of simplicity but of
complexity and many scientists and many
disciplines were involved in the
development of this drug and I will
mention perhaps one or two perhaps
biased towards personal logical matters
but I will have I trust in the written
written version of this talk
opportunities to acknowledge my
colleagues and family and friends more
generously many things were going on at
once at this time the microbiologist
microbiologist to describe the bacterium
as a new species of streptomyces the
fermentation chemists and biologists
isolated the mystery substance that
killed worms and they persuaded the
microorganism to puce that substance
more abundantly and analytical
analytical chemists determined this
chemical structure it's actually a set
of closely related molecules that we
named aver mengdan the synthetic
chemists found how to make an even
better version of it and so I will show
you the structure
this is picture I took if dr. immoral in
1990 and you can see that he has not
changed at all this is the original
stuff a ver mikta nor even Becton b1a
this simplified slide there's a lot of
detail left out of this it's also known
as album actin so that's the original
stuff on modified but organic friends in
chemistry they acknowledge that
microorganisms can make molecules that
humans cannot but they also seem to
believe that only a chemist can make it
properly and so they they tweak these
things and modified and so what they did
was to make a better version of it which
is shown here now I trust you all have
noticed the difference but just in case
you haven't just focus on the upper
right hand corner where you see here and
here the 2223 bond between those carbon
atoms each of them has been and it has
been given another hydrogen so this was
accomplished by hydrogenation of a verme
actin to make ivermectin
and so this ivermectin is 2223 dye hydro
a permanent B 1 a B 1 a just been one of
these closely related molecules so they
had made this change by adding hydrogen
so they thought not surprisingly that
they would like to call this stuff
another Abram actin but ivermectin
because it's been hydrogen had been
added but it was pointed out to them and
that in some language hayver
means testicle and so that's how
ivermectin became ivermectin
despite being unique in its origin
ivermectin not as many relatives many of
them are on in
on the market in animal health and
there's a whole whole family of these
related compounds called macro cyclic
lactones and there is a vast literature
on those meanwhile the parasitologists
had found out which worms it would kill
and the biochemists found out how it
would kill or rather how it would
paralyze them because with peril with
with parasitic worms paralyzing them is
just as good or from the worms point if
you just as bad as killing them the body
itself will get rid of paralyzed burns
with this flood of information that was
being gathered the project was given
developmental status so even more
disciplines more scientists became
involved and I will just mention one as
an example of many very different
scientific disciplines and I want to
mention for a moment the Veterinary
parasitologists we had many very
parasitologists not only from our own
country but from from Vetri schools all
over the world and they were brought
into this project and they had an
astonishing
brett's and depth of knowledge of
parasites and they set up trials to
assess the efficacy of ivermectin
against many different kinds of
parasites in many different kinds of
host animals in many different lands and
I think their expertise was actually
essential to the success of ivermectin
and animal health where it became the
dominant anti-parasitic agent sometimes
things that one are thought of as bad
turn out to be good if a broad-spectrum
anti-parasitic agent fails to be active
against some particular important
pathogen that
Julie oblivion for that drug candidate
if it misses some very important
parasite but not necessarily so in the
case of dog heartworm the the
significant pathogen is the adult worm
stage and ivermectin is not active
against adult heartworms taraf alaria
images in dogs however in the routine
treatment of dogs to get rid of their
worms and emphasizing the routine
treatment that goes on all the time it
is actually dangerous to kill that adult
worm killing the worm the adult worm is
quite likely to end in the death of the
dogs can be fatal to dogs it can be
fatal to the reputation of the
veterinarian and so that is not a good
thing to do so ivermectin turns out to
be ineffective exactly where you would
like it to be ineffective SIL ivermectin
is used all the time to control
heartworm disease in dogs it's used as a
preventative agent and as it happened
before the discovery of ivermectin I had
instituted a program of her heartworm
research at Merck and Linda Blair and I
had set up the life cycle in the lab
mosquito to dog life cycle and we had
that going just when we needed it to
test ivermectin against heartworm and we
found that it's active against a pre
adult phase so we were able to do the
research that led to the development of
a once-a-month
treatment the first once-a-month
treatment for the prevention of
heartworm in dogs the potential value of
ivermectin was in humans was was never
overlooked
I had always insisted that our written
objectives include the development of
drugs for the control of parasites of
people and when my colleagues John
Edgerton and Linda Blair found that
ivermectin was active against the larvae
of the parasite uncus circuit
Kahless in the skin of horses then I
knew it was time to take further action
and my chief dr. Jerry Birnbaum
enthusiastically approves my proposal to
invite dr. Bruce cokeman and Australia
to do a trial against another uncle
circle species uncle circle got to Rosa
in cattle and we gave him funds to
support that research which he did and
he's an expert on it and again he found
that ivermectin was effective so at that
time we had information suggesting that
ivermectin might be useful in humans
against a variety of parasitic worms
including hookworm for example but it
was clear when one would evaluate the
situation that the best way to meet an
unmet need in human medicine would be to
have it used against river blindness
which is caused by yet another species
among kazakh on Costa Rica volvulus
so dr. Burma dr. Birnbaum and I took
that message to the top level of
research management at Merck and company
it was an exciting moment for both of us
we made our pitch and at that time the
head of research at Merck was dr. Roy
evangelist who himself was a physician
and the chemist and they listened very
intently to our story and they approved
a trial of ivermectin in humans a very
cautious trial in patients that had the
very early stages of river blindness
long before there was any actual
blindness they would have the infection
that causes river blindness but they
would have light early infections so
this was a very cautious trial at the
beginning and this was one of a series
of trials that were set up and directed
by dr. Muhammad as is who was one of
Merck clinical directors and he was in
charge of doing this and he set up this
trial
in Senegal and it was undertaken by dr.
as is and dr. died a low of the
university of takara and dr. lariviere
of university of paris and there are
colleagues and they showed that
ivermectin was active against the
microscopic larvae the baby worms in the
skin of people and that was of course
thought to be exactly what is needed the
trial had to be very cautious because
there had been some precedent that it
was dangerous to kill those microscopic
worms but this turned out not to be
dangerous and in fact to be very safe
and do you understand why the activity
of that against those larvae is
important it's necessary to understand
that in river blindness unlike the
situation was dog heartworm it is the
offspring these microscopic progeny is
that caused the damage to the skin and
to the eye and eventually leads to
blindness as well as skin disease and
serious itching and so killing those
those larvae can prevent the onset of
disease you can block it before it gets
going and that's what I've imagined does
in 1987 dr. valueless was then CEO
president of American company and he
announced that the company would donate
the drug for the use against river
blindness and this led to an
unprecedented donation of the Medus an
unprecedent translation of this donation
of the drug into the actual distribution
of the drug and that was a very
complicated business and it was
undertaken by many groups I will just
mention a couple of them you've heard of
some of them already but I mentioned the
World Health Organization and mercs
own Mectizan donation program which was
set up from the very beginning to make
sure that it was properly used and the
Carter Center
in Atlanta Georgia but our many many
other agencies involved in this process
and also there were many leaders
involved in this process many directors
of the various components and I will
just mention one of them and I feel I
must mention one because he is Swedish
he is dr. Buren he Lafourche and I am
honored that he is here for the
activities of this week I will now show
that a few more slides this is a
sculptural representation of a
well-known iconic scene in endemic areas
where you have endemic areas that are
endemic for river blindness where you
have adult people who are blind have
been led by children and often connected
with the sticks sometimes three or four
or five people all connected to one
child and this is a well-known thing and
this is where the river blindness
program comes in and the impact of
ivermectin and river blindness in terms
of the extents of that impact which has
now been developing over many years is
something that is now a well documented
and well established and not for me to
discuss here I just want to show a few
pictures of the some of the very early
treatments that I was an observer for in
the early program
this is dr. Mohammed Aziz America a
clinical director who was responsible
and who chose the place to do the first
trial chose the place did people to do
it with and made sure that all was done
according to proper protocol I'll show
another side of people there's three
people here of great significance my
wife and I are talking to two of the
people beer on the left and I don't need
to say why my wife is important you
already know that but the two people on
the right are of tremendous importance
one is Jimmy Carter the head of the
Carter Center former presidents of the
United States and he
because of his past position was in a
position to be very influential in
helping the distribution program and
then standing next to him second from
the left second from the right and this
picture is dr. Roy Vangelis and he was
the one who had to make the decision
whether what to do with this drug and he
was the one who decided it would be
donated and there is no point really in
talking about various people who have
suggested it in various parts of the
world at various times because the
important thing is who who considered it
who were in a position to do something
about it if you have to be accountable
for it
then it becomes a big decision to make
and that's why Roy evangelist made such
an important decision now I would like
to not talk further about how great an
impact this was but rather I want to get
back to that Mouse assay the test system
with which I began the operation of that
assay was simple as I have explained the
operation was simple but so was the
principle of it sinking it up was a
different matter that was innovative
thinking on the part of my colleagues
but the underlying principle was simple
it was bizarre but it was simple and I
have described it this way you line up a
series of infected mice you treat each
Mouse with an unknown amount of an
unknown substance that might not be
there and then you check to see if it
works on the face of it it seems to find
in the face of what we are taught about
science with a dwell regulated system
and its emphasis on measurement but we
need to understand that this too is well
regulated to science the empirical
research based on observation and trial
and error
screening of substances has been the
foundation of the discovery of
anti-parasitic drugs but in recent
decades that screening approach has been
beaten into disrepute and deaths
weighted and his many played in many
places being abandoned and when it is
abandoned we cannot know what price has
been paid in non discovery I have
recently made a proposal I'm sorry
before I get to that proposal let me
just show these last few sides I had a
chance to observe the early trials this
is in a remote village in northern Togo
where I saw the first community-based
trials in remote places like this where
villagers would gather together in a
school yard under the tree for treatment
you see on the left a girl standing on
the bathroom scale to be measured
because at this stage very detailed
records were kept it turned out later
that that bathroom scale was a
unnecessary expenditure of a high-tech
instrumentation and it was long since
replaced by a measuring stick which is
much easier to use much more efficient
children were given a tiny pill which
they could easily swallow and have a
drink of water and open their mouths to
show that they had swallowed it this is
a village elder but when you in the one
of these gathering situations where the
treatment was being given when dursa
would see people like this blind elder
who had that leopard skin caused over
many many years of infection with river
blindness and had been preceded by
really excruciating itching
unfortunately in those situations you
would also see a man like this a blind
man for whom treatment had come too late
because ivermectin will prevent
blindness it will not cure it but what
the good part of those
collection to visit under three under
the tree or in schoolyard were seen
collections of children who would now be
safe and we'd no longer grow up under
the threat of the skin disease and the
itching and the eventual blankness I
recently made a proposal for more
broadly searching the world for my
natural products especially
microorganisms as a means of finding new
molecules for development as
chemotherapeutic agents that might be
useful to supplement to some of the mass
treatment programs that are currently
underway to treat various diseases but
nevertheless
Kemah therapeutics control should not be
seen as the ultimate objective unnatural
measures are likely to have unforeseen
natural consequences and the broader the
activity spectrum of biodynamic
substance the more we must guard against
the hazards of indiscriminate use and
since we cannot count on discriminate
use we should try to control the disease
without recourse to chemical agents
there are very few acceptable
antiparasite vaccines but we might yet
learn how to make better ones and more
of them and we also might be able to
devise public health measures to subvert
parasite life cycles more subtly than in
the past in late afternoon I often climb
a nearby hill not a mountain it's just a
grassy half-mile hill called half-mile
hill and from the top there is a
marvelous vista of woodland and lake and
the sky often tinted with color as
evening falls and it is a moment of
uplifting tranquility but when realizes
of course that not everybody lives
amidst such natural beauty and in
conditions of peace and around the world
there are many people making heroic
efforts to redress that terrible
imbalance
then one of their objectives is to
improve global health and as we bring
science to bear on such problems I hope
we will keep in mind that solutions are
sometimes to be found in science that is
simple thank you